avec nous pour ce club le féliologue
Bruno cotreize bonjour Bruno merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous bonjour et
docteur chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire et Quentin comme tous les
vendredis nous a rejoints bonjour
Quentin on va parler de la réforme des
retraites nouvelles journées de
mobilisation hier avec un nombre élevé
de participants mais une mobilisation
émaillée par des violences dans
plusieurs villes alors etons à un
tournant de la contestation vous nous le
direz ce sera le débat et puis dans ce
contexte social la question de la visite
de Charles III en France se pose le
monarque doit arriver dimanche à Paris
en grand dîner est prévu lundi soir au
château de Versailles peut-il se tenir
dans ces conditions Charles III qui sera
au Sénat lundi matin pour prononcer un
discours devant les parlementaires
Quentin on va découvrir avec vous le
parcours de sa visite sénatoriale ce
sera dans quelques instants d'abord en
regardant ensemble actualités dans nos
régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions se sont
bien sûr c'est manifestations
mobilisations hier dans plusieurs villes
de France on va aller à Lyon on retrouve
Sandra Fargier bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et bienvenue dans ce
club on est ravi de vous recevoir vous
êtes journaliste au progrès sans grande
surprise évidemment Sandra ce sont les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites qui font la une du progrès ce
matin un mouvement qui s'essouffle
mais en tout cas si le gouvernement
espérait un essoufflement du mouvement
contestataire semi visiblement pas le
cas pour preuve les rayons ils étaient
20.000 manifestants selon la préfecture
55000 selon les syndicats un regain
d'alliance d'ailleurs qui selon le
contage des syndicats des trône la
mobilisation déjà record du 7 mars
dernier on voit que la colère elle dure
quel s'amplifie on a même comme dans
d'autres huiles de France des
manifestations dites sauvages
quotidiennes depuis cette mars date à
laquelle Elizabeth borne avait annoncé
que le gouvernement allait recourir au
49-3 pour faire passer
la réforme des retraites mais la
manifestation de ce jeudi à l'appel de
l'intersyndical elle était un peu
différente d'autant plus que le
Président de la République s'était
exprimé la veille une allocution qui
n'avait pas vraiment convaincu nos
interlocuteurs que l'on avait que
interrogé pardon sur nos départements
qui étaient les manifestants hier Sandra
alors dans notre colonne on est au bien
entendu l'ampleur de la mobilisation
mais aussi on sait aussi intéressé aux
personnes qui sont venues pour la
première fois manifester quelle était
leur profil pourquoi rejoignent-il le
mouvement on a rencontré par exemple
Samuel un étudiant qui est venu exprimer
son ras-le-bol alors son combat c'était
la réforme l'utilisation du 49-3 mais
pas seulement on voit bien que le
mouvement il dépasse maintenant un petit
peu le simple problème des retraites
on a aussi croisé Maxime qui n'avait pas
manifesté depuis plus de 15 ans et qui
pense aussi que l'inflation ou encore
les problèmes climatiques méritent que
l'on s'engage en tout cas il s'accordait
sur un point c'est que l'allocution du
Président de la République la veille
avait largement jeté l'huile sur le feu
il y avoir une radicalisation du
mouvement
on voit bien en tout cas qui devient
violent à chaque un peu plus violent à
chaque manifestation
sur l'ensemble des départements sur
lequel le progrès est implanté on
recense de nombreuses interpellations
des incidents des dégradations
rien qu'à Lyon on comptait 67 blessés et
11 interpellations dans la Loire ce sont
trois personnes qui ont été placées en
garde à vue dans l'un il y a aussi eu
des affrontements entre les manifestants
et les forces de l'ordre alors qu'il me
radicule radicalisation pardon du
mouvement c'est vraiment pas exclu c'est
en tout cas ce que laisse entendre des
manifestants que l'on a pu interroger
hier
pour ses participants de la première
heure ils sont là ce devoir que le
gouvernement fait la source d'oreille et
pour eux il y a plus qu'une seule
solution c'est toucher l'économie en
créant peut-être des blocages un peu
plus important que ce qu'on a pu
connaître jusqu'à présent qui pour
engendrer des pénuries et d'autres sont
très claires ils pensent vraiment que le
mouvement va se radicaliser et il
s'agitent même le spectre de retour des
gilets jaunes merci beaucoup
merci Sandra on regarde la une du
progrès ce matin manifestation d'ampleur
à Lyon dans le dur c'est le titre que
vous avez choisi ce matin à la une du
progrès merci d'avoir été avec nous et à
très vite dans ce club est-ce que Arnaud
Bruno on est dans une radicalisation de
ce mouvement ah bah c'est clair qu'un
tournant a été passé et très clairement
tous les témoignages en atteste depuis
l'utilisation du 49-3 et encore plus
depuis l'intervention l'interview du
chef de l'État qui a donné le sentiment
de fermer absolument toutes les portes
même si le chef de l'État a voulu tendre
la main en disant il faut que les
indicats se réengagent il a utilisé à
nombreuses reprises ce verbe réengagé
mais on voit que depuis 49 fois plus
réaction du chef de l'État on est passé
à autre chose on est passé dans une
autre dimension là le conflit est en
train de muter dans autre chose et on
voit maintenant des thèmes sur les
panneaux des manifestants on voit
d'autres thèmes qui apparaissent
effectivement qui refont à la crise des
gilets jaunes la question du délit
démocratie la question de qu'on ne
vivrait pas en démocratie voilà on voit
qu'on est en train de passer à autre
chose et surtout nous voyons mettre dans
tous les jours des images de mobilité
urbain qui flambent de poubelles qui ne
sont pas ramassées ou d'ordures pas
ramassés de poubelles en plastique qui
flambe elle également et ces images sont
productrices de quelque chose en
elle-même les images deviennent
pratiquement un acteur de cette crise
avec le sentiment que tout le monde
regarde ça en disant ça échappé au
contrôle d'une certaine manière on ne
voit pas l'issue social on ne voit pas
l'issue politique on est dans le dur
comme le progrès le disait et on est
dans l'impasse
si vous voulez ce qui s'est passé hier
en effet bon je partage ce que je viens
de dire Bruno kotrise c'est à dire que
il y a trois caractéristiques à mon avis
qui sont nouvelles dans ce qui est en
train de d'émerger depuis hier la
première c'est que d'abord dans les
mobilisations il y a un rajeunissement
des mobilisations il y a des jeunes qui
étaient dans ces mobilisations et ça
c'est nouveau
ça c'est un premier point deuxième point
c'est que on voit que elles sont
beaucoup moins contenues qu'elles ne
l'était jusqu'à maintenant le niveau de
violence c'est d'une certaine manière
exacerbée et le troisième point c'est
que il y a si vous voulez une tournure
politique qui est en train de de se
développer c'est que
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui est en
première ligne aujourd'hui clairement
c'est même pas sa première ministre et
on voit bien que l'intervention qui
d'ailleurs moi j'ai pas bien compris le
timing de cette intervention finalement
intervenir avant une mobilisation je
trouve que on voit bien ce qu'il a
volonté c'était de couper la route à la
mobilisation pensant qu'il allait faire
baisser l'attention et le problème c'est
qu'il n'a pas fait baisser d'attention
il a exacerbé donc oui il y a
aujourd'hui une évolution une mutation
semble-t-il mais la mutation on l'a vu
apparaître dès la semaine dernière avec
l'annonce du 49-3 mais c'est la première
fois alors c'est vrai qu'on voit des
violences depuis plusieurs jours mais
c'est la première fois qu'il y a des
violences d'une manifestation à l'appel
de syndicats et Quentin ça veut dire
est-ce que le moment est crucial pour la
terre syndicale puisque les débordements
sont de plus en plus violents voilà et
c'est le cas en fait depuis que il y a
eu le déclenchement de l'article 49-3 de
la Constitution mais c'est vrai que
c'est en fait le premier rassemblement
de l'interseynécal depuis ce 49-3 mais
nos reporters hier dans les cortèges ont
interrogé les leaders syndicaux sur ce
risque de débordement incontrôlé en
marge des manifestations écoutez dans
l'ordre Laurent Berger puis Philippe
Martinez c'est au micro de Jonathan du
priez et Adrien pain ce qui se passe
dans un certain nombre de villes avec
les retraites aux flambeau et des choses
pacifiques qui se passent ça se passe
des fois très tôt le matin aussi c'est
pas que le soir il y a beaucoup de
mobilisation syndicale tôt le matin à
différents endroits
et ça c'est bien enfin ça va continuer
dans les jours à venir et puis il y a
les rassemblements et je sais pas si
vous parlez de mobilisation sociale mais
enfin des rassemblements le soir avec de
la violence qui m'inquiète qui
m'inquiète à double garde d'ailleurs la
violence qui a exercé à travers les
biens et les personnes et puis aussi ce
que ça implique comme comme
confrontation entre ces manifestants et
la police pas de crainte de débordement
on sait qu'il se passe des choses en
marge des manifestations c'est pas il
s'en est passé la dernière fois
l'avant-dernière fois nous ce qu'on sait
c'est que les la détermination la colère
elle s'exprime de façon pacifique dans
les cortèges avec des slogans clairs net
précis
ce sont des violences qui se déroulent
en marge des cortèges syndicaux mais qui
sont quand même des routes qui se
déroulent quand même pour la première
fois lors d'une journée syndicale est-ce
que on entend l'inquiétude de Laurent
Berger est-ce qu'il a raison d'être
inquiet est-ce que ça peut aussi se
retourner contre les syndicats et
violents en tout cas tout le monde a
raison d'être inquiet hier effectivement
beaucoup d'observateurs disaient qu'on
voyait pour la première fois en retour
en nombre des fameux Black Blocs les
estimations étaient peut-être entre 1000
1500 personnes donc ça commence à faire
un nombre extrêmement important de gens
qui viennent là pour entre guillemets
cassé
l'ordre public s'affronter directement
aux forces de l'ordre on voit des forces
de l'ordre qui sont super sollicitées
depuis de très nombreux jours qui ne
peuvent pas sans aucun doute se reposer
donc on voit que tous les ingrédients
sont réunis pour qu'effectivement la
situation deviennent extrêmement
volatile est-ce que ça peut se retourner
contre les syndicats pour le moment le
soutien dont ils dispose et la preuve
qu'ils ont apporté pendant de nombreuses
semaines d'une capacité à être à jouer
vraiment pleinement leur heureux ça va
être les porte-paroles d'une opposition
sur une question sociale je ne crois pas
en tout cas dans l'immédiat parce qu'on
voit que les syndicats ressortent quand
même avec une image assez de toute la
séquence le niveau de confiance dans les
syndicats
sans commune mesure avec celui dans les
dans les partis politiques donc pour le
moment ils ont me semble-t-il bien pris
leur responsabilité on voit les paroles
des deux responsables des principaux
syndicats qui sont dans l'appel à
l'apaisement et d'une certaine manière
de renvoyer le gouvernement l'exécutif
vers ses propres responsabilités
il y aura pas de retournement de
l'opinion le problème en plus c'est que
c'est installé l'idée que Emmanuel
Macron ne reculait que lorsque le
rapport de force parfois dégénéré en
violence parce que tout le monde en
mémoire ce qui s'est passé avec le
mouvement des gilets jaunes le mouvement
des gilets jaunes a finalement réussi à
obtenir une partie de ce qu'il
souhaitait alors pas tout mais notamment
le retrait de la taxe l'augmentation de
la taxe carbone après les événements du
1er décembre enfin les trois premiers
les trois premiers exacts des gilets
jaunes et donc en effet s'installe cette
idée parmi un certain nombre de
contestataires souvent d'ailleurs assez
jeune que finalement le pouvoir n'écoute
que une certaine forme de violence et
d'ailleurs quand on regarde les études
d'opinion c'est intéressant c'est que
vous avez aujourd'hui une part non
négligeable de l'opinion qui
pas juger alors même si elle reste
minoritaire qui va juger que cette
violence est légitime ensuite moi je
suis assez d'accord je pense pas que à
ce stade au jour où on parle que
l'opinion publique ce retourne
globalement aujourd'hui quand on regarde
de près les études d'opinion elle fait
porter la responsabilité des blocages
dans lequel nous nous retrouvons plutôt
au gouvernement est plutôt à Emmanuel
Macron d'autant plus encore une fois
Emmanuel Macron ne sait pas laisser pour
l'instant beaucoup de portes de sortie
donc si vous voulez ça rend beaucoup
plus difficile sa position et la
perception qu'il peut disons dégager
dans l'opinion publique donc je crois
qu'en effet on est dans une situation
qui est une situation de blocage
clairement on va voir la réaction du
gouvernement
c'est ce matin il fait un décompte très
précis de la journée d'hier 903 feux de
mobilier urbains ou de poubelles 457
interpellations en France 441 policiers
et gendarmes blessés il vient de le dire
sur ses news on écoute le ministre de
l'Intérieur
quand on a mis à l'intérieur on dort peu
par fonction mais on dort peu parce
qu'on n'a pas envie qu'un policier un
gendarme a manifestant évidemment décède
c'est le pire qui puisse arriver ce
n'est pas arrivé dans des conditions
pendant d'extrême violence les Français
regardent la télévision et doivent se
dire comment cela n'est pas encore
arrivé alors je dis à toutes et tous
attention la violence devient de plus en
plus forte nous devons condamner ces
extrêmes de l'ultra gauche parce que
sinon il peut y avoir un drame dans
notre pays et cela n'a rien à voir
encore une fois avec la contestation
sociale qui est tout à fait légitime
doit se réveiller et condamner cette
violence et l'extrême gauche le mis de
l'Intérieur prolonge le message du chef
de l'État lorsque le chef de l'État
faisait bien le distinguo entre les
manifestants dans leur sincérité
encadrés par les saints voilà encadré
par les syndicats et puis ce qu'il
appelait la foule et on voit que d'une
certaine manière du côté de l'exécutif
on commence aussi à ouvrir le le
parapluie le paratonnerre qui est de
dire si jamais il y a un drame nous on
est on est bien on est dans la
préparation on est solide sur nos sur
nos appuis de renvoyer la responsabilité
à une
ultra gauche ce sont les mots du les
mots du ministre et on traduit c'est la
déclaration du ministre traduit quand
même que ça commence à faire beaucoup de
dégâts parce que les chiffres qui la
cités sont tous anodin de mémoire il y a
pratiquement 500 personnels forces de
l'or ou de sécurité qui ont été blessées
ça commençait à 141 400 quand même
quelque chose de très significatif et
qui renvoie à l'opinion un message que
la situation commence à être extrêmement
extrêmement tendue et problématique
à cette expression qu’employait mercredi
le chef de l'État les factions et les
factieux
qui a fait beaucoup réagir oui mais si
vous voulez c'est ce qui est
difficilement compréhensible c'est que
le gouvernement et le chef de l'État
tiennent exactement le même discours
qu'il tenait au moment où le mouvement
des gilets jaunes démarrait et donc on
voit on a l'impression qu'on reproduit
la en l'occurrence mais repondu la même
scène là avec finalement des
mobilisations qui ne sont pas du même
ordre et de la même nature que celle que
l'on a connu lors du mouvement des
gilets jaunes le discours était déjà
plus audible au moment des du mouvement
des gilets jaunes mais il est encore
audible aujourd'hui parce que ce sont
les corps intermédiaires qui se
mobilisent si vous voulez moi je pense
que cette situation elle est le produit
de plusieurs facteurs elle est le
produit en effet du contournement
permanent des corps intermédiaires on
l'avait vécu avec les élus locaux lors
de la crise des gilets jaunes on le vit
aujourd'hui avec les syndicats et d'une
certaine manière avec les parlementaires
à cette occasion donc ça c'est un
problème ensuite vous avez une
communication qui me semble-t-il
aujourd'hui n'opère pas ne fonctionnent
pas on voit bien que là aussi les études
qui ont été réalisées tout de suite
après l'intervention du président de la
République témoigne finalement de la
difficulté c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire des Français à s'approprier le
message du président de la République
donc si vous voulez ces facteurs cumulés
créé les conditions de ce qui constitue
aujourd'hui une crise sociale
vraisemblablement une crise politique et
qui sait peut-être demain une crise
institutionnelle donc on est quand même
dans une séquence qui est
particulièrement préoccupante oui on
voit effectivement aussi
accroître le sentiment qui est déjà en
France quand même très très important de
manière générale ce sentiment
d'incroyable défiance vis-à-vis de la
politique et de l'univers de la
politique qui est perçu comme totalement
déconnecté pas du tout empathique
récemment j'entendais que des
parlementaires même comment c'est
utilisé l'expression d'un président qui
cohabite avec le peuple c'est quand même
un message extrêmement fort et c'est
vrai que le chef de l'État concentre
tout sur lui aujourd'hui il n'a au
ménagé aucune porte de sortie il a fermé
les unes après les autres toutes les
voies on va dire un petit peu comme une
sur une autoroute à un moment donné il
faut quand même une voie de sortie là on
ne voit plus d'aucune voie de sortie et
par ailleurs je dirais qu'on est dans
une en plus dans un contexte où la pièce
maîtresse de notre système démocratique
l'élection et de moins en moins vécue
comme ayant régler la question de fond
qui est quel est le grand choix que se
donne le pays pour une durée de 5 ans et
au sein d'un système politique assez
fragilisé l'acteur pivot le président de
la République en l'occurrence Emmanuel
Macron concentre maintenant un niveau
d'insatisfaction très aidé l'une de
popularité qui va quand même pas très
bien et une image qui est incroyablement
clivée écrivante et qui ne cesse de
l'être et on va continuer de parler
d'Emmanuel Macron mais on va d'abord
regarder avec vous Quentin les réactions
politiques à cette journée d'hier et aux
violences on commence par celles de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il était invité
effectivement du 20h de TF1 5 minutes
d'interview à la fin du JT de Gilles
Bouleau le mouvement ne va pas s'arrêter
a dit le chef de fil de la France
insoumise il faut multiplier les actions
a également dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
dit aussi chercher une issue positive et
faites une proposition écoutez oppose au
président retirez votre texte et donner
le dossier à ceux dont c'est le boulot
les conseils d'administration
que les conseils d'administration de la
sécurité sociale où il y a dedans les
patrons et les représentants syndicaux
ben c'est à eux de s'arranger pour
décider les cotisations peut-être qu'il
faut augmenter les choses qu'il faut
bref c'est à eux de le faire ils l'ont
fait dans le passé ils savent le faire
qu'est-ce que l'État vient faire
là-dedans c'est pas lui la caisse de
sécu elle appartient
à la suite c'était sur France 2 avec une
grande soirée politique organisée autour
de Caroline Roux 6 1 8 et autour de la
table de la gauche jusqu'aux
rassemblement national on peut le dire
Ariane chacun était un peu dans son
couloir la preuve avec la majorité
présidentielle qui campe sur la position
fixée par le chef de l'État mercredi
écoutez Clément Beaune les ministres des
Transports qui reconnaît que le pays
traversent un moment difficile avec des
mobilisations très importantes
écoutaient la suite
je suis absolument convaincu qu'elle
dise une opposition de beaucoup de gens
à la réforme des retraites
non et on l'a vu précédemment j'y
reviendrai mais je crois qu'elles disent
aussi beaucoup de choses beaucoup
d'autres choses et que dans les
mobilisations il y a un malaise il y a
une colère il y a des gens qui disent je
sais pas pourquoi exactement je suis là
il faut l'entendre je crois que c'est
notre travail collectif notre
responsabilité collective qui touche au
pouvoir d'achat qui touchent aussi
de dire que on a un débat qui est plus
général aussi que la question des
retraites on l'assume mais il y a pas
que ce sujet et on aurait tort de nous
traiter que cela et on l'entend le
ministre de renvoyer vers de futurs
dossiers sur les services publics les
salaires à la pénibilité mais donc dans
les prochaines semaines les prochains
mois et à droite Quentin on est un peu
entre deux
président du groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale défend toujours la nécessité
d'une réforme des retraites mais dénonce
la méthode et l'attitude du chef de
l'État écouter c'était sans doute pas le
bon moment c'est évident et je pense que
le président n'a pas vu et oui on a
aussi le sentiment le Président il doit
tout ça de loin
être dans un bar de nuit pendant à
Kinshasa pendant que on parle de la
réforme de retraite tout ça crée un
problème donc oui il faut reprendre il
faut apprendre le dialogue il faut que
le Président de la République rompe avec
avec cette alignement on termine avec le
rassemblement national qui était
représenté par Jordan Bardella qui
dénonce également l'attitude du pouvoir
écouter les gens qui ont écouté le
premier République hier auraient aimé
entendre des mots de d'empathie de
bienveillance de l'amour je pense qu'ils
ont envie ils ont envie d'être aimé
surtout d'être respecté par les gens qui
sont au pouvoir alors quand on passe par
la force quand on humilie les
représentants démocratiquement élus du
peuple
manque de respect au peuple français et
je pense qu'il faut remettre un peu de
un peu de un peu d'humain et un peu de
bienveillance dans la politique et la
politique c'est pas un truc froid c'est
pas un tableur Excel non on le voit
c'est arrow sur Emmanuel Macron c'est
lui vraiment qui est cristallise la
colère et les oppositions
alors si on prend quand même un peu de
distance clairement de toute façon dans
toutes les grandes crises que le pays a
traversé depuis 1958 ça se concentre et
ça se cristallise très rapidement autour
de la figure du président de la
République c'est j'allais dire la nature
même de nos institutions qui fait
remonter la contestation au plus haut
niveau de l'État donc de ce point de vue
là j'allais dire la figure d'Emmanuel
Macron ne dérange pas à la règle mais
il y a quand même malgré tout une
expression personnelle et politique et
parfois même comportementale d'Emmanuel
Macron qui renforce j'allais dire cette
cristallisation autour de la
personnalité du chef de l'État et avec
quelque chose qu'il faut rajouter c'est
que la lecture que Emmanuel Macron fait
des résultats électoraux de 2022 est une
lecture qui ne correspond pas à ce que
pensent une majorité de Français et
c'est à dire que lui il interprète ses
résultats électoraux comme un quitus qui
lui est donné pour finalement dérouler
un agenda qu'il qualifierait de
réformiste la réalité ce que ce n'est
pas du tout ce que ont voulu faire les
Français et d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière les Français on ne donnant pas
une véritable majorité au président de
la République lors des dernières
élections législatives lui ont envoyé ce
message que il ne pouvait pas gouverner
sans ne pas respecter les
contre-pouvoirs et notamment le
contrevoit le contre-pouvoir
parlementaire et en l'occurrence
indéniablement la séquence que nous
traversons donne l'impression qu'il n'a
pas du tout écouté ce message là
oui dans l'extrait que vous venez de
passer j'ai trouvé terrible
l'analyse que propose le ministre disant
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui sont
dans la rue et qui disent je ne sais pas
pourquoi je suis là alors là vraiment on
est au cœur du problème parce qu'on va
encore une fois que en creux ça renvoie
l'image de l'exécutif qui considère les
personnes qui se mobilisent comme des
gens qui sont aveugles et ignorant leur
propre intérêt et la le message que nous
a livré le chef de l'État au fond c'est
ça fondamentalement vous êtes ignorant
aveugle à votre propre intérêt et
heureusement je suis là pour vous
montrer le chemin et vous guider ce
n'est qu'un mauvais moment à passer
après tout nous dit-il et donc là on
voit effectivement une déconnexion qui
est extrêmement importante c'est pas du
tout le propos qu'il faut tenir en ce
moment au contraire en ce moment il faut
reconnaître la sincérité des gens qui se
mobilisent et prendre au sérieux ce
qu'il ce qu'ils disent et puis ce qui
est vraiment intéressant on voit cette
problématique qui est en train de
s'affirmer beaucoup d'ailleurs dans le
débat public
qui est une demande de de calmer le jeu
au sens un peu plus général qui est le
thème de de l'empathie l'ancienne
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
Ségolène Royale vient de publier un
livre qui dit il faut de l'amour en
politique et donc on voit qu'elle a un
sujet avec un sentiment la dimension
émotionnelle du rapport à la politique
est très importante et là on est dans un
grand moment émotionnel les images que
nous voyons actif profondément des
sentiments à la fois de peur de colère
d'inquiétude et on a le sentiment que du
point de vue de l'exécutif on a quand
même beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
comprendre tout ça et on en revient à la
personne d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il
peut incarner ce que dit Bruno est-ce
que lui il est de nature à apaiser le
pays
en tout cas ce que l'on voit depuis une
semaine c'est que les tentatives qui ont
été les siennes mais aussi de son
entourage d'une certaine manière parce
que quand même quand madame born dit
finalement le fait que la motion de
censure n'est pas été adoptée constituée
une victoire dire c'est très mal perçu
parce que on est quand même passé très
près j'allais dire du coup de ce Mons en
l'occurrence donc c'est même une forme
de mépris qui est envoyé à la
représentation
parlementaire ce n'est pas une victoire
c'est tout simplement j'allais dire oui
c'est vraiment une victoire par défaut
parce que finalement une partie de
l'opposition a décidé de ne pas censurer
le gouvernement donc je pense que tous
ces éléments tous ces signaux en effet
envoie des messages qui sont extrêmement
négatifs dans un pays qui finalement
considère aujourd'hui que ces élites ne
sont pas à l'écoute que ces élites ne
les représentent plus donc infinix
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'image d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
pour une grande partie des Français il
incarne le il incarne satellites qui
aujourd'hui ne sont plus en mesure non
seulement de mener le pays de construire
un projet mais d'avoir disons presque un
sentiment démocratique vis-à-vis de de
la société et en effet c'est une crise
qui à mon avis est beaucoup plus
profonde et qui dépasse largement la
question des retraites le problème c'est
que elle a tellement été mal géré au
début qu'aujourd'hui comme dans toutes
les crises et ça c'est la dynamique des
crises importantes vous avez d'autres
thématiques qui vont progressivement
apparaître donc on est au début de
quelque chose d'une colère d'un
mouvement qui va s'élargir et se
cressaliser sur d'autres sujets que la
réforme visiblement c'est la direction
c'est en train de prendre c'est
difficile parce que Arnaud vient de le
rappeler dans une crise il y a une
dimension d'un processus donc par
définition de c'est pas très bien où
est-ce qu'il va où est-ce qu'il va aller
mais on voit le fil directeur qui va
clairement de la crise des gilets jaunes
à aujourd'hui ce fil conducteur ce fil
directeur c'est cette question
effectivement d'un pouvoir qui est perçu
comme un pouvoir qui ne sait pas écouter
et on voit que la grande problématique
derrière et qui ne vraiment pas
uniquement d'Emmanuel Macron c'est sans
aucun doute quelque chose qui est
inscrit bien avant c'est ce sentiment de
l'élection qui ne suffit plus à éponger
toutes les contradictions toutes les
demandes sociales et effectivement les
le cœur du sujet on l'avait vu déjà
pendant le premier mandat le cœur du
sujet c'était effectivement un deuxième
tour d'élection présidentielle chargée
d'ambiguïté font charger d'ambiguïté
quand on passe de 28% des exprimés à
même 50 58 etc ça veut dire qu'il y a
quand même des gens qui viennent vers
vous au deuxième tour et qui ne vous ont
pas choisir au premier tour et on ne
peut pas faire l'impasse sur cette
question on ne peut pas faire
l'hypothèse qu'en simple en 15 jours ils
ont adhéré d'un seul coup un programme
et en pleine crise sociale il y a un
événement qui va arriver ce week-end en
début de semaine prochaine c'est le roi
Charles III qui arrive en France
dimanche au menu notamment en dîner à
Versailles qui fait polémique on va y
revenir avec vous mais l'un des temps
forts de cette visite ce sera le
discours qu'il prononcera devant les
parlementaires français au Sénat et
Quentin grâce à vous on va découvrir en
avant-première le déroulé de la visite
de Charles III au Sénat vous êtes glissé
dans les pas du monarque on regarde
la visite de Charles III au Parlement va
commencer ici nous sommes dans la cour
de la présidence du Sénat c'est ce qu'on
appelle le petit Luxembourg le roi qui
va arriver par cette porte qui donne sur
la rue de Vaugirard et être accueilli
dans cette cour par deux sections
d'infanterie ainsi que la fanfare de la
garde républicaine qui pour l'occasion
sera à cheval sur le perron c'est le
président du sénage à un marché ainsi
que Yaël Braun pivey la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui accueilleront
le monarque sur le 3 qui a ensuite va se
rendre au Sénat
c'est là que la visite du roi Charles
III au Sénat va commencer à proprement
parler le tout filmé par des dizaines de
caméras il y en aura une trentaine
positionnée tout autour du palais du
Luxembourg le roi qui va monter
l'escalier où je me trouve tout comme
l'avait fait sa mère la reine Elizabeth
c'était en 2004 lors de la visite d'État
de la souveraine en France et c'est
d'ailleurs cette visite de 2004 qui a
inspiré Charles III pour ce séjour en
France
en salle des conférences le roi va
signer le livre d'or qui sera positionné
ici devant la cheminée c'est dans cette
salle aussi un que sont réunis et les
centaines de députés et de sénateurs qui
seront venus rencontrer le roi
dernière étape pour le roi il prononcera
un discours ici depuis la tribune du
Sénat un honneur supplémentaire par
rapport à sa mère Elisabeth qui s'était
contenté d'un discours mais en salle des
conférences cette visite au total
devrait durer 45 minutes
et voilà Quentin vous êtes magnifique
dans cette émission
[Rires]
est-ce que c'est important dans le
contexte actuel et des relations
franco-britanniques cette visite de
Charles III ce discours qu'il va
prononcer devant les parlementaires au
Sénat c'est effectivement très important
d'une part parce que la dernière visite
d'État du monarque britannique je crois
de 2014 la reine Elisabeth et là on voit
qu'un contexte qui est un contexte on
essaie de retisser la relation
franco-britannique la relation
franco-britannique et quelque chose de
fondamental en Europe absolument
fondamental depuis le brexit
effectivement il y a on voit que il y a
matière à renouer cette relation la
relation n'était visiblement pas
excellente entre Emmanuel Macron et boys
Johnson par ailleurs Emmanuel Macron a
envoyé des signaux au nouveau Premier
ministre britannique pour renouer le
lien donc ça se situe dans ce contexte
un peu plus un peu plus général et ça se
situe aussi dans un contexte ou noble ne
l'oublions pas il y a quand même eu des
supporters de football britannique n'ont
pas été très bien traités
par la France récemment là on accueille
le monarque il y a un vrai enjeu de ce
point de vue là et puis j'imagine que la
la presse la presse britannique va
scruter de très très très près les
conditions dans lesquelles nous allons
accueillir leur souveraineté pour le
moment des conditions dans lequel va
arriver au chapitre de la finale de
Coupe d'Europe
avec ce qui s'était passé avec les
supporters de Liverpool je crois non bon
c'est clair que les relations
aujourd'hui quand même avec le
Royaume-Uni se réchauffe il y a eu le
sommet il y avait pas eu sommet
d'ailleurs franco-britannique depuis
quasiment 2018 donc c'est un sommet qui
marque malgré tout un regain j'allais
dire de relation plus soutenues avec
avec l'ombre après il y a le contexte
dans lequel se déroule cette visite
c'est-à-dire un contexte qui est un
contexte en effet social dont on vient
de parler donc non seulement la presse
britannique va scruter les images mais
la presse française va scruter les
images également et ceux qui sont aussi
dans la rue vont scruter les images et
les principaux leaders de la
mobilisation vont scruter les images il
faut pas que ces images soient trop en
décalage avec ce que le pays est en
train de vivre parce que voilà qui va
rajouter j'allais dire d'une certaine
manière du ressentiment au ressentiment
donc il faut que la communication qui
accompagne cette visite soit une
communication qui à mon avis soit plutôt
sobre voire un peu austère
du grand dîner d'État qui est prévu au
château de Versailles évidemment dans ce
décor onctueux avec des dizaines
d'invités de marque est-ce que la
question doit se poser de maintenir ce
dîner est-ce que dans le contexte actuel
le chef de l'État peut tenir un tel
dîner on imagine mal qu'on puisse
recevoir le monarque britannique sans un
dîner un peu d'apparat on va pas lui
donner le pack lunch de l'école
britanniques au souverain donc
effectivement il faut quand même le
recevoir c'est pas seulement le chef
d'État britannique c'est aussi celui qui
est normalement le chef du Commonwealth
c'est-à-dire c'est un écho international
gigantesque une visite du souverain
britannique dans le monde anglophone
c'est très suivi donc nous on peut pas
se rater à Versailles
voilà mes textes actuel on imagine mal
aussi on imagine aussi le souverain
britannique est traité différemment on
se rappelle que Poutine a été reçu à
Versailles lui également donc voilà il y
a quand même un moment donné où d'état à
état on ne peut pas quand même un moment
donné
ne pas rendre hommage un souverain qui
est en visite
en 30 secondes rapidement 30 secondes la
symbolique de Versailles est une
symbolique très spécifique dans
l'imaginaire politique français dans un
moment de très grande tension sociale
les questions peuvent se poser et
j'imagine qu'elles se pose aujourd'hui y
compris à l'Elysée d'après ce que l'on
croit savoir donc on va bien voir quel
sera le choix que sera le président de
la République et on
suivra axenna je vous en parle dans
quelques instants le temps de regarder
ce qu'elle a une de vos quotidiens
régionaux on parle évidemment de cette
journée de mobilisation
[Musique]
et Quentin très forte unanimité
aujourd'hui encore des une de la presse
régionale voilà signe de l'importance
des cortèges on l'a dit 300 vilains où
il y avait ces mobilisations et un
regain dans le nombre de ces
mobilisations donc on voit ce matin
encore aux quatre coins du pays sur
toutes ces que l'on a collectionné on
note que le mouvement est impressionnant
on regarde dans le détail Quentin
plusieurs titres mentionnent le 49-3 et
oui et si c'était ça qui avait vraiment
relancé le mouvement social le 49.3 cet
article de la Constitution qui permet
d'adopter un texte sans vote la rue
contre le 49.3 écrit ainsi elle Alsace
la Charente Libre titre sur le fait que
le 49-3 a rallumé la mèche je cite
Angoulême près de 15000 participants ont
défilé dans le calme raconte le journal
on se demandait si cette neuvième
journée de mobilisation était un baroud
Dona et bien clairement non répond la
presse quotidienne régionale regardez
cette réponse de la rue et réponse aussi
à l'interview du chef de l'État écrit Le
Dauphiné Libéré à Grenoble ce 9e appel à
la mobilisation a pris la forme d'une
réplique massive à la fermeté Macron
concernant la réforme des retraites La
Dépêche du Midi à Toulouse parle d'une
contre-attaque de la rue enfin le
populaire du centre c'est à Limoges qui
parle d'un retour de flamme
d'un tourne voilà la montagne a
Clermont-Ferrand qui dit que le ton se
durcit ils étaient 20.000 hier à
manifester dans la préfecture du Puy de
Dôme regarde mobilisation sur fond de
tension écrit de son côté West France
enfin Paris Normandie à Rouen qui évoque
la colère qui monte d'un cran et la
principale différence c'est sans doute
que la jeunesse était présente hier dans
les cortèges
par la Provence à Marseille coup de
jeune c'est le titre de du journal ce
matin dans les pages intérieures on lit
que la jeunesse fait gonfler la
mobilisation cet arrivée de la jeunesse
est très préoccupante pour l'exécutif
c'est ce que dit dans les pages
intérieures le sociologue Michel
virevorka merci beaucoup merci content
d'avoir été avec nous merci Bruno
cotresse merci Arnaud Benedetti et je le
disais on va se retrouver lundi pour une
journée spéciale sur Public Sénat
puisque vous l'avez compris on suivra
bien sûr la visite de Charles III au
Sénat je vous retrouve pour deux
émissions évidemment on se retrouve pour
la matinale 7h30 9h une émission
spéciale consacrée à cette visite de
charleutronc se penchera notamment
beaucoup sur les relations
franco-britanniques et sur l'importance
de cette visite et puis à partir de midi
vous suivrez bien sûr en direct la
visite de Charles III au Sénat content
vous serez avec moi voilà tout à fait on
va faire cette déambulation que j'ai pu
aussi faire en introduction on va la
suivre en vrai avec le roi à la place
voilà et ce discours qui se déroulera au
Sénat mais c'est un discours devant tous
les parlementaires français puisque les
députés seront également présents au
sein du Sénat au suivant bien sûr
congrès au Sénat exactement voilà ce que
réussi à faire Charles III merci
beaucoup merci Quentin merci Bruno merci
Arnaud et on se retrouve donc lundi pour
une journée spéciale très bon weekend
[Musique]